the Joe Rogan experience um like
sometimes one king to think Theo and aya
roast each other and he's so good at it
sometimes I was like I'm gonna sit out
man just go ahead man I got nothing I've
ran out of material you know go ahead so
the things he says are so Theo like he
Theo is like there's a few guys
Theo's one of them Sebastian's another
one that have like a style economy that
you will never be able to explain to
someone they got to go see him like you
got to listen to him because it's so
strange where most bikinis think podcast
is mostly me saying something pretty
average and then feel just saying them
up most outlandish thinking me laughing
my ass off the funnest show ever because
you guys go back and forth at each other
it's very funny so funny man yeah he's a
unique dude very unique dude as unique
as they get yeah he's not straight right
now I guess yeah he's in Australia right
now he goes yeah this is this morning
yeah man got a koala come what come to
the hotel and I went oh [ __ ] man those
things have chlamydia so make sure you
wash your hands and he goes [ __ ] I have
some things to he better wash his roadie
was that way to Brody had that unique
style to he's so special man oh so
special is very just know it yeah yeah
yeah you just know it man I be were
asking what it's like to work with Theo
all you guys I said with Theo it's like
he's the LeBron James economy so
creative I'm just that shitty coach on
the side trying to manage trying to
manage this ball game not the [ __ ] get
out man he's but he's just I mean
there's other guys that are funny but
they're funny in like a regular way like
oh he's really good as jokes are great
he's got a great presence he's great on
stage but Theo's like try to explain
that you can't explain that you gotta go
to some magical cluster of dark magic
from New Orleans where he'll say
something I'm like
there's certain guys I can watch and
I'll go oh he's definitely his IQ might
be higher than me mine but I see how he
got there with this premise of a joke
with fee oh my god that I have no idea
how he got that it's not happening
[Applause]